[Música]
cria apresentar-vos o ego
é que eu que tenho o privilégio de
conhecer e de trabalhar em conjunto com
outros da alta performance o éder é um
ser humano extraordinário que nos faz
acreditar que tudo é possível
tal como todos nós eu também vacilou
duvidou e destino
mas eu não tenho dor e vai atrás de seus
sonhos stroessner que tenham deles
conhecer um aumento de rendas e
diversidades procura soluções e
estratégias de ter mais objetivos para
cumprir a deriva
procuro vento favorável que traga para o
que nem sempre é prova de que é difícil
para uma pessoa que nunca desiste
história do eldorado mas não há grande
coisa mas temos que viver foi de 16
constantes e pequenas batalhas que
precisa vencer o inter lembra como eu
vou ser criança e nunca perder a
capacidade de sonhar com história e eu
aprendemos que nunca devemos abandonar
os nossos sonhos que nunca devemos
desistir
eu nunca quis que o deu e eu também não
me quero - talvez não tivessem a noção
do conquistámos da via que terá para
sermos respeitados na sua história
[Música]
[Aplausos]
estreando em ver que as palmas agora
serão como a renda isso aumenta quando
se trata de atuação e principal mentor
isto é uma coisa que eu tenho é muito
engraçado porque o nosso acerto não se
tem é que o que é ficção de que o que é
real e outras porcarias cento cabendo às
mais fatal em qualquer ficção porque eu
acho que a contar quando ainda assim aos
prantos porque temos esta capacidade de
imaginar
ainda vamos enfrentar o inter que tem
uma dificuldade grande quer falar se
pode transformar em uma época que não
faço a minima ideia quem é que está a
testar em conta que houve quem vou
tentar pelo menos em 15 minutos
há muitas pessoas com profundo tão séria
como é que é possível treinar atletas
para a alta competição para fazer coisas
maravilhosas para o europeu
como é que eu posso ajudar
eu tenho uma função deixada em herança
entrevistas talvez você já tenha visto
algumas já com visão nostálgica mais
vistas
eu já falei pra você ver algo que faça
diferença entre atingir objetivos que
essas cargas trabalhar quanto à
exoneração de outros falamos do everton
assim autorizou não é então a única ong
quando questionou por que não fazem
então será um exemplo é deco trata aqui
hoje
antes fora do rn profundamente do que
qual é o meu papel tamanho que neste
trabalho que eu faço vos falar muito
pouquinho porque eu não gosto não gosto
mas fala todo três pessoas com quem
trabalho outro trabalho que eu faço é só
de mim estava terceira o que eu vou
dizer qual era porque era médica aulas
quando perguntava o que eu crescer e
fazer com a minha filha fácil
enfrentá-los sentado e com nosso plantel
é o que ela quer ter algo assim eu quero
um tiro e ela mostra vagas não consta no
contrato coisas entrar no imóvel era
bailarina e cantora que também quer ser
médica coisas que eu tinha era uma delas
é aquela que é hoje acho que nós não foi
reduzido o tempo todo e com as quais não
foi médica todos o que é real e eu não
fui eu que eu tinha que fazer e não vai
dar nos a todos mas não com as coisas
que não fazemos aquilo que eu sei fazer
da copa uma vez o pai me ensinou a falar
com minha neta do escritor chris weitz a
candidata estava cheia porque tu quer
ser médica porque gostava mesmo era a
pessoa chegar lá outra qualquer coisa lá
em um dia a vida das pessoas
estava a ver o corpo mais uma máquina um
carro popular entra para o sucesso das
peças do carro de castro autor só uma
coisa e nós fomos lá fora
e foi neste momento que meu pai é
basicamente um internauta ficar como
está e eu fiquei a saber eu dava muito
jeito a pena que eu via quando for da
carrinha porque o cska show 30 carros de
até três vezes e não ceda josé ganhão
homem sofreu ferimentos que às vezes até
hoje manter sempre na minha vida eu
tenho uma crença muito limitador do que
achava que nunca comenta uma senhora
bresser com 35 pontos além de ter muita
coisa que eu fiz pra falar eu tenho 14
anos na vale que aqueles três 20 30 não
estava na altura então fazer qualquer
coisa para cumprir o meu sonho ser
coutinho poderá então fazer coisas entre
as pessoas e austrália - as pessoas
acharem que para ser co alimentos e
apenas esperava fechar ouviram falar
para a ordem do dia
o coxa dá pra ver isto a ser certeza que
já ouviram esta especial em que o
aeroporto em nosso estado pela situação
atual situação dos já o nosso que
estariam estar com o code faz esse
trajeto normalmente e que não é assim e
com tv maringá e paulinho faz aqui é
outra forma mais rápida e mais 25 para
chegar ao objetivo
a jornada que estão por cima da hora até
funciona ou funciona pra que confina
apenas cumprindo as metas e objetivos da
malta gosta de coisas que pensar em
coisas que você não mudou e não coisas
que eu gosto das coisas que nós possamos
comunicar a equipa que as outras pessoas
e ninguém vai dizer com shows locais
então para compreender sonhos e metas
que tal gente sim fazer coisas de volta
final no grupo 1 primeiro marcador da
época passou ou qualquer outra coisa
porém vinham com uma equipa da primeira
liga com quero trabalhar em dobro do
nosso campeonato sai apenas um minuto em
mais do 15º lugar na zona de expansão
para o quinto lugar do campeonato
o ano passado foi um grande campeonato
ganharam tudo
tudo muda muita coisa
é uma ferramenta muito útil outro
convite coby que se fosse ao contrário
nada como membro pelas coisas que eu não
falo nem em coaching ea prever deu passe
para iniesta exemplo nós tiveram
valorizar o nosso ponto a cada um de
vocês pensam voz o objetivo das
comissões têm um instrumento situação do
mercado
o dinheiro que eu também me dá tempo que
o time deu conhecimento se começar a
analisar todo mundo pronto a tempo do
ponto bem que o governo não dará um
passo nesta terra
agora se eu pensar no ponto que eu quero
ou não de qualquer chegar sem limites
como se fosse possível eu só tenho que
fazer o que elas fazem plástica e sim
para confecção de bonecos é assim que eu
faço com os atletas de alta competição
que eu trabalho e sim que o réu deve ter
50 dias sem marcar sim sentar em campo
com uma única vez ainda assim eu sabia
que quando empatou a final iria marcar o
gol da vitória
foi assim também que o era quando eu
conheci esta questão esta imagem entrou
aqui porque o estado é quem mente ao
contrário inverta a situação e com a fé
coisa extraordinária
ela não querendo ela entrou com a
primeira ação que eu fiz com o everton
coutinho trabalho pode durar dois anos
a primeira ação que eu fiz com ele eu
plantaria qual herói que atingiu esse
ano não tem grandes objetivos que eu
quero é jogar
tava no braga época 2014 2015 só cai não
temos um objetivo e um sonho mas um
sonho com essa consciência de que o
campeonato inglês vamos fazer mais uma
vez dar um prazo e vamos trabalhar em
suape
mas é crível que os 212 muito bravos
minutos soares
uma delas é que é um tempo vão
candidatar já não joga mais o braga não
tem ajudado numa coxa e traição
a premier league é só ligar mais
vendidos do mundo e portanto tal revista
aconteceu porque dois anos eu voltei com
as fotos que o que eu faço muitas vezes
quer fazer trazendo para o assunto acham
que não tem cão é pra nós fazemos para
coisa passando a se juntar vende-se
inicial era de que a batalha para ganhar
sem pensar nisso é a minha memória e
quantificar o real valor
eu estou na casa dela quando acho que é
um jogador que esteja 2 1
nunca mais vi de desastre mina é maluca
da cabeça ou em amanhã nunca vamos
trabalhar assim foi e nós começamos a
trabalhar de trabalho tinha propostas da
premier league taciana foi repassada
ontem que a proposta causa desta derrota
do braga para a premier league é um
exemplo para todo o país cresce todo
este processo era das naves leu até tudo
que eu fiz para conseguir os objectivos
que se propôs a marca assim com essa
precisão em qual situação contada pelo
próprio eder do dia da final que opõe o
que é que eu tenho sou como todos nós
com seu dever e claudina do rs todos os
golos com que o trabalho do tcu nesse
triste tendência em vir atrás do sonho
foi exatamente isso que eu fiz tal como
vocês conhecerão hoje aqui quando viram
tudo aquilo que nossos vizinhos são
pequenos gravado na memória também fica
gravado na memória e no primeiro dia da
sessão quando chega a casa e chegar à
casa eo meu marido está lenta mas sentar
assim ao vivo pela primeira vez que uma
castanha palestino em uma sala que era
também contada no livro
então o meu marido e eu chego a casa em
londres protestando na pauta já sabes
que eu não possa contar com estas coisas
estão em construção
não posso partilhar o objetivo é que o
momento é que a linha do teto que é uma
conta mais
o objetivo do evento é ímpar premier
league e seis meses faz aquela cara de
quem viu as imagens aqui hoje aqui é
mais ou menos essa cara que eu fiz eu
faço aquela cara ainda assim nem todos
têm que respeitar investimentos e que
essa divisão série b de 2010 houve uma
elevação de 80 são procedimentos são os
mesmos
minha nossa filha do aposentado walter
pela fina
essa pole graças a deus que não será
fácil colocar não só quem sente
aprendemos coisas por lá uma coisa
pessoal jamais jamais teria ajudado ela
era com a filha que ela chegue em porque
também é muito limitador da experiência
do que eu já saí eu acho que não vai
acontecer porque nós somos totalmente
contra justin que há coisas que não
volto a gravar como intenção é que ela é
cara do meu marido e eu com cinco anos e
nunca mais vou esquecer utente tem
twitter com cadastros fabiano e vendem
menos né
não só não esqueça como taxista outra
das questões quantas vacinas
quem é que há quem se lembra que calçou
no dia 15 de outubro
a gente entrou com um requerimento que é
o menor foi o emblema agora nem outubro
na capital
desta vez o percurso vai tocar eu
acredito que permaneçam os fantasmas
todos aqueles que se lembram onde é que
estavam em um gol 2001 quando foi o
atacante torres gêmeas lembra
quase toda a gente mantenha os pés não
não não não tenta matar em pé
o avançado motor o que aconteceu aqui
porque todos nós assinamos em função
aqui é por isso que nós estamos nós
estamos construindo tudo aqui e vamos
fazer um teste
agora eu penso que toda a gente formada
então acho que não envolva esperam que
um crime ver quando vocês vão
basicamente com cara de voz foi assolado
o corpo achado pelas recentes no chão
agora vem a parte física e agora vamos
investir na sessão vão buscar o vosso
sonho é que o espaço está indo ao ataque
do bota feira que o que vocês querem
para esta unidade da vossa vida a longo
prazo se espera em um barraco empresa no
próximo mês em que o que vocês querem
conquistar aquela experiência
querem presenciar aquela novidade
pode ser aqui o que vocês querem para a
sua família a vossa equipa é que eu faço
isso todos querem atingir canção você
acha ser alguma coisa ninguém vence
neste ponto estou aqui já começa a ser
postas cá é muito intensa do que quando
vocês venham a sonho que eu tenho é que
o classmate querem podem ir lá só lhes
digo uma coisa todos nós sobrevivermos
até lá vamos ter 80 ninhos e quando
chegava à sua 5ª região está tentado
esfaqueá las já não vai estar com algum
custo benefício não vão estar com alguma
coisa digital lo passar assim não sai
nesta altura 80 ante aquela altura esta
final tem um tumor na hora que ficava
ali olha que esta roupa quando ele
cortava nós vamos deixar todas as
oportunidades do mundo e não soubemos
aproveitar era magro tinha tudo pra
conseguir as coisas nós queremos fazer o
nosso sonho não vai ter folga
prince e rodney quer que seja que possa
chegar à nossa meta agora é aumentar a
construir agora pelas consagradas e
tentar abrir o vosso alcance fura e
contar uma história inspiradora é quem
tivera vaz pato bragado santa catarina
[Música]